sebastien welcome I'm delighted to be
doing this and I think it's a fabulous
book
I've known Alan Greenspan for many many
years and we work together closely when
I was his last chair and he's a
complicated man and these were
complicated times and I think you got it
about right but let's start at the
beginning
you wrote interestingly about the
influence of his parents could you talk
a little bit about that on his career
choices Alan Greenspan had an unusual
upbringing in the sense that they raised
in the 1930s he was the child of a
single mum his father left his mother
when Alan was only three and then was
this sort of distant figure unreliable
who would sometimes say he would come
and see his son and then not show up and
I think that probably reinforced a
tendency that Alan had to live inside
his own head to be introverted and then
that was further reinforced by two
things from his mother first of all
we're talking about the 30s the
Depression said she had to get an animal
living wasn't easy she worked in a
department store in Manhattan and so he
was left by himself all alone in a house
with kind of distant grandparents who
were from a different you know they were
immigrants and they felt alien and much
older and so he basically was by himself
but then when the family gathered at
parties and holidays and so forth Alan's
mother Rose was a vivacious singer and
she would lean over the piano and sing
in the manner of a torch singer
beautiful haunting chants songs and Alan
always felt she is the center of
attention
I could never match that so this
introversion was then reinforced by
sense of inadequacy but he got his
musical interest from her he did get it
from her that's right and that but I
think then you know the musical interest
he pursued and he became a force a
professional musician for a while after
leaving high school in before college
that was in a way an attempt to get into
the limelight to be in the spotlight to
match his mother and through musical
ability well maybe so but he genuinely
loved music
of course
and and he was good at it what about his
friendship with anger and people come
back to that a lot how do you think that
influenced this thinking then
well huge numbers of Americans read Ayn
Rand and are influenced by Ayn Rand or
they try to read him and it tends to
happen when they're about 19 years old I
mean it's a kind of college thing and
the ideas the libertarian vision are
appealing because they're so simplified
and bold the interesting thing about
Allen is that he met Enron when he was
older you know his late 20s and then he
stuck with her so much that when he was
sworn in aged 50 as the chairman of the
Council of Economic Advisers under
President Ford there were three guests
there the swearing in there were Allen's
mother Iran and Iran's husband so this
was a very close relationship and I did
think anything it had a a profound
effect on his development do you think
she really changed his mind or did she
reinforce is his views and he was one
who believed in the great man and he
loved railroad builders and things like
that
and and certainly reading and Rand would
reinforce individualism and that's what
I think yeah I mean you know alamos
somebody who partly because he was
withdrawn and living in his own head as
a child there was always you know
cutting his own path when he went to
college in 1945 it must have been one of
the most pro-government generations of
American students people there on the GI
Bill paid for by the government yet he
emerged as an anti-government sort of
libertarian so he was going his own way
but meeting an Rand reinforced that and
drove him to build a whole philosophy
whole worldview which was kind of
dormant before you know he was somebody
in the data and empiricist more
concerned with teasing out economic
numbers than he was about a social
vision and Enron brought him from the
data to the kind of political economic
agenda talk about the numbers
fascination a bit and he was a genuine
nerd as we would say today that's
modern phrase but he just loves
statistics of numbers yeah I mean that
was a passion as a child he would be
wheeled out in front of the relative's
perform you know complicated addition as
a kind of performance add and the
baseball stats right he was enough
dancer that's a thing at the Fed you
know Ben Bernanke likes baseball
business right hand baseball so Adam was
part of the baseball tradition in
economics he was also actually more
seriously what I called and part of what
I call the New York school in other
words there was an empirical based in
New York around the National Bureau of
Economic Research which was focused on
just counting the economy creating the
aggregate data which we now see in the
GDP statistics which hadn't existed in
the 30s and so the creation of data the
understanding of how you generated the
best quality data was how he got his
start not modeling not the taking of
data for granted and then the building
of complex mathematical connections
between those data points and I think
this helped him as Fed Chairman to not
just accept that you know productivity
is doing such and such it's reported now
now let's just think about the model
that we might build with that number no
he wanted to disaggregate the
productivity data see what was behind it
and then actually form a conclusion that
the data were wrong crucially in 1996
not led him to perhaps his most famous
quarters Fed Chairman which allowed him
to keep interest rates lower for longer
in the late 1990s yes I was there at the
time and that was very interesting on an
incident because the modelers actually
wanted the Fed to raise interest rates
because unemployment was so low and
their models were telling them raise
interest rates raise interest rates and
Allen was saying I don't see this
inflation something else is going on he
said a little more about that yeah I
mean he basically believed that if
profits were going up and yet
productivity was flat there was a
mystery I mean normal
you know if if you're making more money
it's probably because you're producing
more per worker and so he wanted to look
into that and he had the Fed staff you
know produced sector-by-sector
what was going on with productivity and
it showed that apparently productivity
in service industries you know law firms
and whatever was falling and he said
intuitively it can't be falling it can't
be that you know everybody's getting a
new personal computer and yet they're
producing less
I mean maybe flat would be possible so
by looking under the hood he guessed
what was going on and he got it right
now
I think this actually links to the
post-mortem of the 2008 crisis because
after the crisis one of the common
assertions was well the economics
profession was all tied up in its models
and you know to to mathematical too much
faith in the predictive power of these
models well the interesting thing about
Alan Greenspan is that he never had that
faith he was never obsessed with a
particular model he was always willing
to question it and and test stress test
those data inputs and so I think the
funny thing is if you'd wanted to choose
a Fed Chairman who was perfectly
intellectually prepared not to be
trapped and caught by surprise by the
crisis you might have chosen alan
greenspan that's the irony yes I think
that's right
I remember once walking into his office
to just to wish him a happy birthday
after I'd left the Fed I said Alan are
you having any fun and he said oh yes
let me show you this and he pulled out a
stack of printouts much of your book you
talk about sort of inconsistencies and
and in a sense this is one of them but
you start with a very nice anecdote
about the gold standard can you say a
word about that and about his shifting
and rather inconsistent he was about the
Gold's dinner well you know as a young
person around an R and he believed in
the gold standard and that was almost an
article of faith with IRA and the
characters and her books
believe in the gold standard and when
Atlas Shrugged one of the big novels by
Hanlon was published Allen presented
iron Rand with a miniature gold bar to
celebrate the publication so this was
very deep in his worldview and if you
believe in the gold standard you don't
need a central bank right because you
don't need to move interest rates around
it's all automatic one of the most
extraordinary things I discovered I knew
that Allen had given speeches under the
auspices of the iron Rand Institute and
I wanted to find the transcripts which I
knew must exist somewhere so I went to
see all these followers of iron Rand
from that period and one of them hidden
away in the woods of Virginia in a cabin
had a basement with a fantastic filing
system and there was the 300 page
transcript of Allen speeches in 63 and
64 and reading through these I came
across this quote the creation of the
Federal Reserve get this the creation of
the Federal Reserve was an historic
disaster so talk about inconsistency I
mean that was part of his view that as
you say if you have the gold standard
you don't need the Fed later of course
he became the embodiment of the said the
personification of fiat currency so he
went all the way to the other extreme
yes and even argued that you didn't need
a monetary rule you had to play it by
ear right there was a middle ground that
Milton Friedman espoused which was not
gold but not just money printing there
would be a fixed amount of increase in
the monetary money supply every year and
the the Friedman rule was kind of quasi
gold sort of in there I mean it was
another discipline and as you say Allen
was pretty determined to reject that in
favor of discipline I'm in favor of
discretion it was his discretion of
course maybe this fits with what you
hinted at earlier you know the believer
in iron Rand believed in great men
including himself yes but he was also
quite shy and often unsure of his the of
his views but let's move on to bubbles
because bubbles are a very interesting
part of this this history you write that
early on he saw the crash of 1929 as
causal in the Great Depression and yet
by the 1990s he was not so worried about
the stock market bubble that we were
obviously having at that time right I
mean it's amazing you know just as I
said one exciting discovery was those
tiny round speeches
earlier on Alan Greenspan had written a
paper in 1959 which was sort of lost I
think he talked about it to friends a
little bit but the actual paper was in
the PhD thesis which magically
disappeared from New York University
library after he became Fed Chairman I
mean friends of mine who had great
reporters really really tried hard to
get hold of that PhD thesis when he
became Fed Chairman because they wanted
to see what was in it and they were told
once it's gone we can't find it now I
know we're supposed to have all the PhDs
that we awarded can't find it sorry
anyway I would be in Alan's office and I
would say and I'd ask questions about
his early intellectual development and
Alan Greenspan's eyes would go like this
a bit and he would look at like this and
after a while I looked up to and I could
see this fat binder on the Shelf and I
said looking at it Alan it be great to
have your PhD thesis in there guessing
what it was and when he gave it to me
and I read it now there was this 1959
paper in which as you say it's all about
how central banks must respond to asset
bubbles and it's based on the nineteen
twenties experience and it says that you
know look compared to inventory cycles
these asset booms and busts are much
more disruptive to a stable pattern of
economic growth so central bank's must
deal with bubbles and yet you know that
was the young that was the prescription
from the young Greenspan as you say the
mature Greenspan didn't follow it know
talked a bit about the dot-com bubble of
the of the 90s sir right well that was
when I was at the Federation yes and so
I'll say what I think but of course you
you will correct me because you were
really there but what I what I saw from
reconstructing it through the
transcripts and through in
interviews of people is essentially that
a key moment came with the collapse of
long-term capital management the hedge
fund which blew up in the fall of 1998
and after that the Fed cut interest
rates to stabilize the markets from the
four-letter cut it
they cut rates three times yes we had a
world crisis going on there was there
was of course yes so-called Asian
financial and Russia had just thrown up
as well so there was a legitimate
concern with financial market
instability and the Fed as I say did
these three interest rates cuts then in
early 1999 in my view things are
stabilized and it was time to take back
that insurance the cuts have been
justified with reference to the crises
LTCM and so forth
once those crises had passed I would
have thought that there the cut the cuts
would be taken back they were not taken
back fully until late in 1999 and in my
view this is the crucial period when
tech valuations went from very high to
absolutely crazy high and and he had
worried much earlier about a crazy high
right when it wasn't so crazy back in
1996 actually he made this famous speech
about irrational exuberance and he
intended to send a signal with that and
he did but later he was less concerned
this is another respect in which you
have no most Shakespearean tragedy going
on I mean the man who knew the man who
did talk about irrational exuberance who
understood that asset prices could ever
shoot who knew that that could be very
dangerous as it had been with a Fed in
the 1920s he had all the right
intellectual formation to respond to the
tech bubble and yet he didn't well I
would argue though we didn't have the
right tools what we would have had to do
to the short-term interest rate which
was a tool we had was raise it very very
high at a time when the real economy was
doing fine and there was no inflation
and in fact I kept saying in FOMC
meetings it's really important to have
very tight labor markets if you don't
have inflation this is doing us a lot of
good I mean this is where I respectfully
disagree and I know where that I'm
disagreeing not just with you not just
with Alan Greenspan that Ben Bernanke
and essentially the consensus the reason
I disagree is that it seems to me that
you know knowing what we know now about
how bubbles can be very destructive it's
worth reducing growth a bit in the short
to medium term with an interest rate
hike in order to have more stable growth
on a sort of two-year or 3-year view and
I think that was the trade-off that was
confronting the Fed in 1999 difficult to
see at the time but in retrospect I
would say that you know we've led the
bubbles matter well but all bubbles
aren't the same the stock market bubble
turned out not to have so such a
devastating consequences the housing
bubble did the combination of housing
bubble and bond market bubble and all
the craziness that went on in the next
decade I talk about that a bit I mean
this is another tremendously fascinating
argument that I engage with in my book
because as you say the the standard view
would be look credit bubbles fueled by a
lot of borrowing a lot of leverage when
they blow up you have a complete
meltdown and it's terrible on the other
hand if it's just stocks stocks rise
darts fall if the holders of the stocks
are not themselves leveraged there won't
be a contagion knock-on effect and so
it's not sound so bad the reason I mean
I think there's some truth in that
clearly leverage bubbles are much worse
but the reason I'm not sanguine about
unleveraged stock bubbles is that when
the Fed was confronted with the collapse
of the tech bubble in 2000 and 2001 the
response was a lot of monetary stimulus
and it was appropriate I mean you need
it to do the stimulus but the
consequence of the stimulus is that you
stimulate what you do is stimulate the
interest rate sensitive portions of the
economy ie
real estate and when you read the
Federal Open Market Committee
transcripts from 2002 to 2003 2004
people knew that this is what was
happening real estate was starting to
take off and it was accepted as a fair
trade off you know we want growth to be
back up we've had this tech bubble that
blew up now we have to compensate for
the fall in corporate investment from
the collapse of that bubble by
stimulating real-estate investment so
one bubble I think it slightly led to
the next that's that's I think that that
part is true but the short term interest
rate isn't the only tool the Fed was a
regulator there were other regulators
there was really egregious stuff going
on at the level of the mortgage
originators they were shoveling out
mortgages to people who couldn't likely
pay them back Ned Gramlich was very
concerned about that
he wasn't concerned so much about the
bubble he was concerned about those
people who were taking out mortgages
that they weren't going to be able to
afford to take to take back but the Fed
and the other regulators it wasn't just
that never really focused on what was
happening to these disastrously
declining lending stead well I think
this is another area where my research
over five years helped me to challenge
the conventional story because in 2001
and one can read about this through
Freedom of Information Act disclosures
you know the Fed did pass new rules on
subprime mortgages and the rules said
there are particularly dangerous types
of subprime mortgage and we're going to
ban them and particularly was an
insurance product which was just a
ripoff of consumers and that was not
allowed anymore and that action you know
you can read Ned Gramlich the Fed
governor who was on the front line of
this stuff debating with alan greenspan
about it and they adopted the rules they
passed the rules at the time the Fed
staff thought that maybe one third of
new subprime mortgages would be
prevented because of the new rules the
problem was that when the Fed staff then
did the retrospective study a few years
later instead of stopping one third of
new
mortgages it's docked 1% because it was
too easy to just get around it and I
think the larger message and lesson that
arises from this is that in a bull
cognized regulatory system like we have
in the United States it's extremely
difficult for one regulator even the Fed
which is the most powerful to pass a
rule and then actually see it enforced
oh I think that's right but there were
other regulators and although most of
the bad stuff wasn't happening on in Fed
regulated institutions that they started
out at the beginning the Fed was the
Prima center part of regulators on
Greenspan could have gathered the
regulators in his conference room and
say look there's bad stuff going out
there what are we going to do about it
there was a collective lack of concern
among the regulators for the rapid
decline in lending standards and the
fact that it was being fueled by
securitizing these lovely these bad
loans of many of them were bad loans and
selling them all around the world to
very eager buyers who thought that they
had high credit ratings and they were
good investments I mean I want to
stipulate that you know of course
there's a lot of truth to what you just
said and in my book I do describe the
crazy securitisation that was going on
and I fault Alan Greenspan because he
had lived through previous derivatives
blew up blow ups I mean you know there
was Orange County which went wrong in
1995 there was Procter & Gamble Gibson
greeting cards there were other problems
with securitisation before and he should
have done more I agree with you but what
they all should have I mean I think it
isn't it's it's easy to focus on now on
Greenspan because he was so prominent
and such of an apparent superhero at the
at the time but I think the messages
were one more thing on this the message
which is maybe underappreciated and
which I hope my book was slightly
correct is that
there were instances in which the Fed
did try so it tried as I just said on
subprime mortgages Alan Greenspan tried
to push back against the GSE is Fannie
and Freddie let's talk about that Katcha
yeah because that was a place where he
was really worried and testified and
talked and made very clear that he was
worried about the thin capital and the
the high leverage at the Fannie Mae and
Freddie Mac in the end he didn't push it
very hard well he went and testified in
Congress I think more than once and he
said that these institutions were
lending too much that there should be
caps on the size of the portfolio he had
an alliance with the Bush administration
at the time which was on the same page
as him and they were pushing I think as
hard as they felt they could to get
regulation on the GSEs now what happened
was that the day before one of the
follow-up congressional hearings on this
topic an ad appeared on TV and the ad
showed a Hispanic couple saying to each
other oh we wanted to buy a new house
but now I hear that Congress is going to
clamp down on mortgages and we won't be
able to get our new house and that's bad
because the politicians are preventing
us from having the American dream and so
essentially this was Fannie and Freddie
putting members of Congress on warning
that if they voted to cap portfolio
sizes they would face a barrage of ads
in their district so it shows the
political limits to what the regulator's
could do yes I think that's true and
they were very powerful lobbyists Fannie
and Freddie but you make the point that
Wow Alan Greenspan was very worried
about Fannie and Freddie and what might
happen if they went bankrupt or seemed
to be going down he was not worried
about big financial and private
financial institutions yeah I mean
that's true I think he had a reason to
be more worried about Fannie and Freddie
because there was a government
implicit government subsidy in their
borrowing cost and they were growing
very very fast and it looked more
obvious that the markets were expecting
them to be bailed out so the taxpayers
were on the hook for Fannie and Freddie
in the way that they didn't look as if
they were on the hook for some of the
others now in the crisis it worked out
they were that they were not for Lehman
but then they regretted that and for AIG
they clearly were so you're right I mean
he should have worried more about the
private banks that were engaged in the
mortgage industrial complex but I do
think that you know he tried on subprime
mortgage regulation he tried on GSD
sighs Tim Geithner the New York Fed
tried on Bank leverage a bit the message
to me from all of this is that
regulation is politically very hard to
do so you have to be willing to consider
interest rates as a way to push back
against bubbles well I would take the
conclusion you have to be willing to do
regulation better and with more view to
systemic risk and what happens if a big
institution or a very interconnected
institution goes down that that was what
no one really anticipated that what
would happen if a Lehman went went down
I come to a different subject for just a
minute though we'll come back the the
Bush tax cut of 2001 I was personally
really mad at Allen for espousing that
but he knows that but that was a curious
incident can you talk about it a bit
sure it was a curious incident because
in some ways you know Alan Greenspan's
emergence into maestra status and sort
of his political acceptance in
Washington was crystallized in 1993 when
he endorsed the Clinton budget package
which raised taxes to reduce the deficit
and he'd always been anti-deficit he'd
always been anti deficit and and he was
there at the State of the Union speech
when Bill Clinton gave the speech he was
there sitting next to Hillary
clapping as Bill Clinton promised to
reduce the deficit so he was known as a
deficit Hawk and then along comes George
W Bush in 2001 with an enormous tax cut
and Greenspan sort of endorses it now he
endorses it with a caveat which is that
he wants a sunset clause such that if
the budget surplus evaporated the tax
cut should automatically go away but
this is a very savvy political operator
Alan Greenspan he knows that that sunset
clause will be thrown out and the
sausage maker that is Congress and so I
think you know essentially he made a
compromise between what he thought the
White House wanted and his conscience he
gave him his conscience and cover by
saying there should be a sunset clause
but really he delivered what the Bush
administration wanted I think that's
right
he also worried publicly about the large
surplus and about what the Fed would do
to execute monetary policy if we didn't
have a national debt I thought that was
fanciful both because the surplus of
that magnitude was not going to
materialize and because there were other
ways of doing monetary policy but he
seemed to really believe that this was a
concern that we might pay off the debt
and then where would the Fed be when
they needed to do open market rubber he
had that concern he also flirted the
concern that you know if if we paid off
the debt then the government with
continued surpluses what would it do
perhaps it would have to start buying
corporate equities this would be
government intervention in the private
market so he raised all sorts of
concerns but they were theoretical
because there was still a very big
national debt and you know as one member
of the Senate said to him you know mr.
chairman if we reach the point when
there's no national debt then let's have
a discussion about it yeah but for right
now that's what I thought yeah wasn't
likely to happen say word about what
most of the audience has probably
forgotten the great moment
y2k yes well in 1999 there was
considerable fear that when computer
systems reset from 99 to 0-0 there will
be a software glitch and that a kind of
programming shortcut adopted in the in
the era when computer memory was
expensive and scarce had caused the
programmers not to build in resilience
around that roll over yes they didn't
put in four-digit dates basically they
put in 9 the 19 was assumed and they
didn't put in a 20 yeah so the Fed got
ready for this and there was concern
that you know people wouldn't be able to
get money out of the ATM checking
accounts wouldn't make transfers
properly all kinds of unforeseen
computer infrastructure on which the
financial payment system depends might
freeze up so the Fed you know positioned
banknotes in regional depots and it got
ready with offered special liquidity
lines to two big banks and so forth and
I think in some ways it was the model
example of a central bank acting to
safeguard the integrity of the payment
system because it worked brilliantly in
the end y2k in technological terms
didn't have didn't turn out to be I
think there was you know a couple of
cash registers in New York in a
chocolate shop oh there were some
incidents in Japan and a few other
places I think - yeah but that was
because they fixed it right so I think I
think that was a great example of
something which because it was fixed we
didn't remember so much exactly and I
remember Alan Greenspan in that period
pointing out frequently in meetings
about y2k that he was a programmer who
knew how to program in Fortran which was
the language of the early computers and
so if they needed help they could call
on him so you might say a word about his
role in in the 911 incident because that
was it was such a big thing for Wall
Street and for the country
and he wasn't even part of it it's
interesting you know he was at a meeting
in Switzerland right at the time of the
attacks I think he was on the flight
coming back to the US and then the
flight had to turn around and go back to
Switzerland
so he was out of touch it was imprisoned
pretty much and then he flew in a
military transport the next day to get
to the feds headquarters and by the time
he got there the team led by the vice
chairman Roger Ferguson was pretty much
in control of the crisis response and
the interesting thing is that I think
this is revealing about Alan Greenspan's
personality he didn't sort of march in
and demand to seize back the levers of
control he was quite happy letting the
others do the crisis response because
what really interested to him was to
think about the right interest rate
policy in response to all of this yes he
was not very interested in payment
systems I experienced that personally it
didn't matter to him very much so he was
not allowed to get back to his office
because it was thought to be an
assassination threat that somebody a
sniper could get him through a window so
he's put in a special office and he hid
away there by himself and he said to me
in these long interviews that you know
in a time of trauma individuals retreat
to their natural emotional comfort zone
and for me it was to go off by myself in
not my normal office and just look at
the data so fast-forward to after the
crash of 2008 he was no longer the Fed
Chairman but he had to come to terms
with his own role could he have done
things differently and was he in part
responsible as many people were holding
him for this can you talk a bit about
how he came to terms with it well the
famous line from his post crisis public
statements is I found a flaw and this is
something he said when he was testifying
in Congress and you know being
cross-examined about haven't he got it
wrong wasn't he at fault shouldn't he
say sorry and so forth and you know he
did say I found a flaw and what he meant
was that he had thought financial
companies banks and non-banks and so
forth would be looking after their own
health protecting their risk exposures
and not therefore being so crazy as to
blow themselves up and take the whole
financial system down with them and this
was a flaw that in the end these people
did take way too much risk and did blow
themselves up now that's stuck rather
and I think it gave rise to the
unfortunate presumption in the public
debate that you know the reason we had
the crisis was that we had a naive
believer in the self policing efficiency
of markets in control and if only we got
rid of that believer and rid of that
belief you know we would have a safer
financial system because if we
understand the markets overshoot then
gee you know we won't make the same
mistake again now in my view this is
both done that for several hundred years
yeah it markets it's a complacent
mistake and it's a mistake about Alan
Greenspan too I mean I know from reading
his early writings
I know because he bought a seat on the
commodities exchange in New York to make
money from market inefficiency he never
believed in efficient markets he always
understood that Marcus could ever shoot
and he understood that banks could blow
themselves up he had studied the 1920s
and 1930s so when I read the transcript
carefully of that I found a flaw
interchange what I thought was he really
just threw that away to try and change
the subject he didn't really mean that
there was a deep flaw in his worldview
he can't have meant that because he knew
that finance is unstable that was
central to his writings over 40 or 50
years so I think the world has learned
the wrong lesson from Alan Greenspan's
legacy they think that we had a crisis
because of an intellectual error whereas
in reality we had a crisis because of
political constraints on what the
central bank can do on what the
regulator's can do as we've been
discussing and if we look at the current
political season I think it would be
foolish to presume that we are any safer
now well we had a crisis for a lot of
reasons that came together I love the
perfect storm
theory rather than than a single cause
theory of this crisis probably was true
that interest rates were too low for too
long and a lot of other things were true
but there was a widespread faith that
somehow large financial institutions
would manage risk well managing risk was
very complicated and there was a lot of
faith they would do it well they were at
fancy new models why did we all believe
that do you think so I think it was a
kind of a faith arrived at because the
rival belief system is even less
compelling what I mean is that you know
people understood that finance could go
wrong I mean anybody like Alan Greenspan
who had lived through the failure of
Penn Central in 1970 the collapse of New
York and bankruptcy of New York or near
bankruptcy in 70s who had you know watch
continental Illinois be bailed out in
1984 who had come to the Fed the first
thing that happens is that the stock
market corrects by 23% then the state
S&L crisis is a commercial property
crisis as a Mexico crisis and the LTCM
crisis there's one crisis after another
I mean he knew that these financial
institutions could get it wrong
why was there that apparent faith that
nonetheless financial institutions would
manage their risks it's because the
alternative faith that the government
could look over the shoulder of bankers
and be smarter about identifying risk
that government faith seemed even less
believable I mean what was the chances
that you know somebody who is
supervising different institutions from
the government comes and visits JP
Morgan and is better at understanding JP
Morgan and the people who work there all
the time and who have a direct financial
interest and tried to manage it properly
I think that it wasn't it say it wasn't
belief that that that markets were
efficient and perfect it's just that
government was also imperfect
be more imperfect come back to the
housing bubble specifically housing
rather than the um Alan Greenspan made
some statements about housing markets
that seemed in retrospect actually naive
and that we couldn't have a national
housing bubble and that people buy
houses to live in them not to sell them
for profit what would make of that it
really was not one of his better moments
you know he came out and said this is
what you what you described and I think
you know it's it is and that's a very
strange one and very hard to explain
except that I think what happened was
yeah in the transcripts you see him
privately debating problems in credit
markets problems also in housing markets
you know that they debated at the FOMC
that this might be creating instability
in early 2004 oh yes he was very worried
about credit cards for example right
there was quite a lot and and part of
that concern with overall asset market
every region included the housing market
so why did you go out in public and say
don't worry there won't be a national
bubble I think it's you know it's the
Fed Chairman in his role as national
cheerleader that he felt he had to be
the bringer of reassuring news now
somebody I quote in my book talks about
Alan Greenspan becoming is reassuring to
the American public as Prozac yes you
talked about it was uncle Alan uncle
Alan uncle Alan has our back you know
there were Alan Greenspan t-shirts and
Alan Greenspan dolls and you know it
just it became a kind of he was the
talisman that made you theatre was okay
to go out and invest whether in housing
or in stocks and once he became that
illness despite himself he was
imprisoned by his own reputation it was
hard to go out and be the bringer of
negative news and maybe you know it's a
bit of psychologizing here but maybe
that shy personality you know raised by
a single
in the 1930s didn't like to confront
society with bad news didn't want to
risk the popularity if he had been more
naturally confident and less needy of
affirmation in some ways maybe he would
have done it differently could it have
anything to do with his admiration of
the great railroad tycoons that are now
talking more about the the major
financial institutions that these very
smart people who were creating and
running major financial institutions
couldn't get it wrong I think there's a
bit of that I mean I think there's a
strand in his mental history which has
to do with JP Morgan that when he was a
jazz player and there was a break
between sets he would be reading
economic history for fun
including the story of you know James
Pierpont Morgan and the creation of the
great Morgan Bank in the late 19th
century of the early 20th century and he
had a reverence for JP Morgan which only
grew when he was appointed the director
of the company and he sat on his board
in the 19 late 70s and early 80's and
you know JP Morgan was the perfect
example of the sadly conservative
careful professional non flashy kind of
bank and I think that that image of her
finance had been maybe did offset that
lesson that he must have learned at the
same time from watching derivatives
dealers at Bankers Trust blow themselves
up it was JP Morgan who basically after
the panic of oh seven 1907 said we need
central bank we need a lender of last
resort and it can't be me because he had
been playing playing that that row come
back to derivatives for a minute because
these fancy financial instruments that
most of us struggle to understand were
exploding
though we'd had derivatives before they
were this was a new explosion all kinds
of financial instruments that nobody
very well understood and yet he resisted
any attempt to regulate derivative so I
mean one of the things that originally
drew me to writing this book was that
Alan Greenspan's
public life from the time he turned the
Nixon campaign until the eve of the
crisis is essentially four decades in
which modern finance was created in at
the start of the story there are no
financial derivatives as you say I mean
there are commodities being traded on
futures markets but no financial
derivatives as well as there being a
fixed exchange rate and capped interest
rates and so the freewheeling modern
system including the derivatives were
created in this period when Alan
Greenspan was at or near the center of
all these debates and I think this is a
key question why not do more about
derivatives especially since they did
show signs of being dangerous I mean
they had caused trouble in 1995 and
there'd been a debate in the late 1990s
about maybe trying to tame them pushing
them from over-the-counter transactions
bilateral swaps between you know one
bank and one company and pushing them on
to an exchange where they could be
better
monitored at least you could see well
yeah and you know why didn't why didn't
more of that happen so there is a famous
moment when the chair of the commodities
future Trading Commission Brooksley born
they advocated that they should be
better regulated and she was shot down
by all the other senior regulators in
town including Alan Greenspan and I
think when you look at that story why
didn't they do more there was a couple
of points and one is that Brooksley born
approached this with the sort of
litigators mentality she was a tough
person she was a lawyer she was a lawyer
she she was substantively correct I
believe them on the direction of policy
how it should have gone but she was not
a good politician in terms of building
alliances around town and so she sort of
blew it by aggressively demanding action
as opposed to her agency from her
it was a turf battle yeah as well it was
seen as a program and so the amazing
thing was that you know Bob Rubin the
Treasury secretary at the time who was
actually sympathetic to the idea of
regulating derivatives became a book
Seaborn opponent because of the turf
issues and because of the way that
Brooksley born drove the issue so I
think she made political errors the
other thing there which we have to
remember and it comes back to our
earlier discussion is that you know
there would have been massive lobbying
by the derivatives business against this
reform it would have cut into their
profits and you only have to look at the
way that the financial Modernization Act
what we could remember as
gramm-leach-bliley passed in 1999 but
after multiple attempts in Congress I
don't know a dozen or something where it
had failed passing new financial rules
was extremely difficult and I think Bob
Rubin and Alan Greenspan and Larry
Summers and I don't know where you add
that you you can speak to that you know
there was a reasonable political economy
point of view which said ideally we
might want to regulate these things more
practically if we try and fight for that
we'll get killed by the lobbies we won't
get anywhere and we will just burnt all
our energy on something and we should
have used our energy for something else
but one more example though of very
powerful people are making a huge amount
of money on the status quo and then it's
hard to change the status quo and no one
stood up against that I thought actually
you didn't mention enough in your in
your treatment of office the the the
element of greed and profiteering not
Alan Greenspan's but all of the
financial sector that was from the
mortgage originators on up that was
profiting so enormous Lee from this the
financial sector grew out of all
proportion if the fat point I mean it
does that mean we have to live with that
well my previous book was called more
money
God write the history of hedge funds and
so I've done greed but you're probably
right that the whole story of the power
of extremely profitable financial
institutions is something that I could
have played out more I think I do get to
it in the Fannie and Freddie example
where it's a clear instance of a very
profitable pair of companies that use
the profits to lobby and run TV ads to
perpetuate the regulations that give it
the profits so regulation creates a sort
of rent for these companies and they use
the profits from that rent to perpetuate
the regulation and it's a terrible
insidious feedback loop well yes and
they were also GSEs they weren't just
companies they were a
government-sponsored enterprises with a
business model that couldn't work they
were being pressured on the one hand to
make money for their shareholders and on
the other to foster more home ownership
and that meant you couldn't be too
cautious but I think the thread running
through all of this is that you know
people knew Alan Greenspan was the man
who knew others who were watching over
the financial system understood a lot of
these issues and the failure in
retrospect was that they knew but they
didn't act and that gets into this
political economy debate about why not I
would question whether they knew that it
could be this big a disaster because a
financial crisis in the stock market is
after all not of crisis in an asset that
ought that is so widely held and if
somebody loses on the stock market his
neighbors are not affected if your house
is foreclosed on the neighbors suffer
one of the things there which you know
again talking about the PhD thesis which
Alan Greenspan wrote and you know I
discovered it I mean one of the central
things was this idea which later became
known as turbine cube heavens cube yeah
and and this is the notion that when
asset prices rise two things happen
first of all individuals feel richer so
they spend more that's the wealth effect
and that stimulates the economy but
secondly companies which see that you
can sell corporate equity for more money
are more likely to go out and create
more corporate equity in other words
they're going to make another factory
they might found another company you
know corporate investment is likely to
go up at a time when and if the the
secondary market is valuing the result
of the investment more highly so this
was central to Alan Greenspan's thinking
in the 1950s and so it followed from
that that when the Nasdaq and the tech
stocks were zooming up to astronomical
Heights it must be pushing an investment
boom that went along with that and sure
enough it was in a fiber optic cable was
being laid under the oceans huge Berman
investment which was driving the economy
upwards equally when the Nasdaq
collapsed in 2000 2001 it was going to
cause a drying up of investment and that
would be serious for the macro economy
so although as I said before leveraged
bubbles are worse you know just pure
equity bubbles do have an effect through
the wealth Channel and through the
investment Channel and Alan Greenspan of
all people and studied this yes and
written about it and and others had
again I come back to the whole the whole
economic establishment failed to pick
this up but the wealth effect on the
downside was enormous when the asset in
question was housing and that certainly
took that took us down further than we
might otherwise have how how would you
sum up the career of Alan Greenspan and
the his his achievements and his
failings well well I mean that's the big
questions they do it in a very
interesting chapter at the end of the
book uh uh yeah I'm asking to recap okay
so I mean my view is that as a analyst
and as a forecaster he was really
sensationally good you know he was able
in the 60s to say that the kind of
Kennedy Johnson policies of pushing
growth upwards would result in inflation
that materialized in the 70s he was
right in opposing the Nixon wages and
price controls that proved to be true he
was right in seeing how the early
iteration of the GSEs were distorting
housing market in the 70s in creating a
kind of conundrum a bit like the one
that came back to bite in the 2000s so a
lot of these things he predicted
accurately he got that productivity call
correct in 1996 that we talked about
when very few other people saw that so
as an analyst he was great
now as a doer as opposed to a sort of
watcher he was less good and he's
sometimes comfortable yes that's right
it really liked being an analyst in in
personality terms yes and again that
comes back to understanding the man so
that's right
and then then that gets into the
question know why didn't he act more
personality as part of it political
constraints and what he felt he could
get away with is part of it this is a
very political person who had learned
all kinds of tricks from working with
Richard Nixon way back in the sixties
and you know that's that's why it's a
story not just about economics it's also
a story about human frailty and a story
about Machiavellian politics yes and I
think about collective mindset not just
Allen's but and if you will about greed
because one of the reasons it's so large
he will make the right call
that some people are making an awful lot
of money and they're gonna descend on
you with both feet if you try to take it
away and that's why it remains today
extraordinary difficult for a central
bank to raise interest rates to pop an
asset bubble because people earn those
assets and they don't want you to do it
and if you can't prove that you needed
to do it which you can't and you'd
always be operating on the presumption
that asset prices may be overvalued you
can't prove it it's very hard to be the
person who picks the bubble it's very
hard but that's why we have an
independent central bank and Ali was
quite courageous in raising interest
rates nobody likes that
in the face of inflation but he was less
comfortable with asset price bubbles
which I would argue would have brought
him into the regulatory domain rather
than just the the interest rate domain
because I'm glad you say that about the
courage to raise interest rates to fight
inflation because that really was
another interesting part of the story in
the George HW Bush administration from
89 to you know that was early on in
Greenspan's tenure and we forget it now
a bit but you know he was under immense
pressure to cut interest rates to the
point that the budget director in the
White House Richard diamond at one turn
and whispering you know the Fed Chairman
is 65 years old he lives by himself he
calls his mother every day isn't that a
bit creepy doesn't it remind you of
Alfred Hitchcock's Psycho I mean this
was really quite nasty political tactics
and despite all that pressure Alan
Greenspan's stood up for the feds
independence and I think in a way almost
created the feds independence I mean
perhaps that sounds like an
overstatement but actually towards the
end of his tenure Paul Volcker the giant
rumpled egg-headed Old Testament prophet
who we remember us the giant who who
slayed inflation and he was that but he
was surrounded in his last year's by
Reagan appointees
the Fed he was outvoted by his own board
once on interest rates twice on
regulation and his authority was
diminishing it was Alan Greenspan who
rebuilt the authority of the Fed and
created its independence and I thinking
in a time like now when experts are
under attack from politicians it
behooves us to study the model of
somebody who was the expert par
excellence who parlayed that expertise
into political influence I mean that was
Alan Greenspan yes I think it also
believes us to figure out what is the
proper role of a central bank now that
we've had it proved beyond a reasonable
doubt that financial instability is a
terrible thing to have happen to an
economy whether it's a domestic economy
or a world economy Thank You Sebastian
for a terrific book that I think
illuminates not just the career of Alan
Greenspan but this complex era in which
we have been living and operating and I